.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Susanne Wille) Die SVP
kommt auf 25,6 %, verliert 3,8 %.
Ernüchterung bei der SVP Zürich,
der wichtigsten Sektion der Partei.
Der nationale Wähleranteil
bricht um fast 4 % ein,
zwölf Nationalratssitze sind weg.
Damit ist die SVP
die grosse Verliererin
der eidgenössischen Wahlen 2019.
Toni Bortoluzzi
ist Vizepräsident der SVP Zürich.
Für ihn
war schon vor der Wahlschlappe klar:
Die Volkspartei
muss grundlegende Probleme lösen,
wenn sie
auf die Siegerstrasse zurück will.
Man muss wieder
pointierter auftreten,
nicht einfach den Erfolg verwalten.
Das reicht in der Politik nicht.
Dieses eindeutige Resultat
bestätigt dies.
Albert Rösti,
der Präsident der SVP Schweiz,
bedauert das Ergebnis,
betont aber,
seine Partei
bleibe klar stärkste Kraft.
Zurücktreten will er nicht.
Wie lange kann sich
Herr Rösti noch halten?
Es ist nicht unsere Aufgabe im Kan-
ton Zürich, diese Frage zu klären.
Aber auch hier
muss man natürlich über die Bücher.
Ob ein Präsident, der
so viel Wähleranteil verloren hat,
noch tragbar ist.
Oder ob man für eine grundsätzliche
Erneuerung der Parteistrukturen ist.
So weitermachen sei ausgeschlossen.
Die SVP Zürich müsse national wieder
mehr Einfluss nehmen und helfen,
die dringend nötigen Korrekturen
in die Wege zu leiten.
* Stimmengewirr *
Im Kantonsrat
gibt es markante Verschiebungen.
Die Bürgerlichen verlieren,
die Grünen und Grünliberalen
legen deutlich zu.
So sieht das im Detail aus:
Die SVP bleibt mit 45 Sitzen
stärkste Partei,
verliert aber neun Sitze.
Die Krise der SVP ist
bereits im Frühling offensichtlich.
Die erfolgsverwöhnte Partei
schwächelt
schon länger in Kantonalwahlen,
aber das Ergebnis der Zürcher Sektion
ist ein Desaster.
Konrad Langhart,
der Zürcher Kantonalpräsident,
macht indes keine Anstalten,
seinen Stuhl zu räumen.
Momentan bin ich Parteipräsident
und in der Verantwortung,
dass diese Partei
weitergeführt wird.
Es ist keine Option,
einfach den Bettel hinzuschmeissen -
bloss wegen einer Niederlage.
Doch es kommt anders.
Die ganze Zürcher Parteileitung
tritt zurück -
offenbar auch
auf Druck von Christoph Blocher.
Rund zwei Monate später
trifft sich die Zürcher SVP
in Hüntwangen
zur Delegiertenversammlung.
Haupttraktandum: die Verabschiedung
der Nationalratsliste.
Blocher hat einen neuen
Vizepräsidenten installiert:
alt Nationalrat Toni Bortoluzzi,
seinen langjährigen Wegbegleiter
und Vertrauten.
* Fröhliche Marschmusik *
Der zuvor völlig unbekannte
Patrick Walder ist nun Präsident
und schiesst in seiner Antrittsrede
scharf gegen seinen Vorgänger.
Die Frage,
die sich uns gestellt hat,
und sich immer noch stellt, ist:
Wie gewinnen wir
die Wahlen am 20. Oktober?
Und alles andere als ein Sieg
kommt nicht infrage.
Die Zürcher SVP
war in letzter Zeit zu langweilig.
Zu normal.
Wir waren einfach
eine Partei unter vielen.
Aber geschätzte Damen und Herren,
wir dürfen keine Partei
unter vielen sein.
Wir müssen wieder lauter werden.
Wir müssen wieder
angriffiger werden.
Und wenn nötig auch wieder anecken.
Langhart soll gar von der
Nationalratsliste verschwinden,
findet Blochers Schwiegersohn.
Wir brauchen keine Leute auf dieser
Liste, die der Partei schaden.
Oder in der Vergangenheit
geschadet haben.
Ich beantrage, Konrad Langhart
von der Liste zu streichen.
Ich begründe das: Ihr wisst alle,
dass er in den letzten vier Jahren
nichts für diese Partei gemacht hat.
Man hat in den Medien
keine Voten von ihm gehört.
* Pfeifen, Ausrufe *
Ja, man hörte seine Voten nur,
nachdem er zurückgetreten ist.
Nicht einmal dann
hatte er die Grösse, ruhig zu sein
und das zu akzeptieren.
Er schoss gegen alles,
was von der SVP kam.
Der Antrag hat keine Chance, aber
die Botschaft ist unmissverständlich:
Langhart ist vorbei.
Bortoluzzis zweite Heimat: Elm.
Von hier stammt seine Frau.
Es ist sein Zweitwohnsitz.
Er ist erstaunt und verärgert,
wie wenig hinter den Kulissen
gearbeitet wurde
in den vergangenen vier Jahren.
Die SVP habe sich auf dem Rekord-
resultat von 2015 ausgeruht.
Die nationalen Wahlen im Herbst
drohen verloren zu gehen ―
so wie die Zürcher Kantonalwahlen
im Frühling.
Wenn so etwas auf eidgenössischer
Ebene passieren würde,
gehe ich davon aus, dass man
die Führung auswechseln müsste.
Denn das ist
wie bei Fussballtrainern:
Wenn eine Mannschaft
keinen Erfolg mehr hat,
versucht man es
mit einem neuen Trainer.
Es ist der zweitwärmste Juni
seit Messbeginn.
Die ganze Schweiz
redet über den Klimawandel.
Die links-grünen Parteien
reiben sich die Hände.
Von der nationalen SVP
kommt dazu nichts.
Jetzt, bei dieser Wärme,
ist es langsam Zeit für Schatten.
Die SVP versucht, das Klimathema
als irrelevant darzustellen -
oder totzuschweigen.
Eine Volkspartei muss zu jedem Thema
Antworten geben können.
Auch wenn es nicht im Zentrum
des Interesses der Partei liegt.
Aber die Antworten
muss man geben können.
Das konnte man z.T. gar nicht.
In Sachen Klima kam man völlig
unvorbereitet auf die Wahlen zu.
Denn von der SVP
hörte man nichts zum Klima.
Man sagte einfach:
"Jawohl, es wird wärmer."
Aber also ...
- Das ist wenig, oder?
Das ist keine politische Antwort.
Es ist einfach so.
Bortoluzzis Hauptwohnsitz
in Affoltern am Albis.
Jetzt gehen wir, hm.
Ins Wohnzimmer,
in die gute Stube.
Die Plakatsujets für den Wahlkampf
der Zürcher SVP liegen vor.
Und auch ihr Slogan ist bekannt:
"Frei und sicher" -
entwickelt von einem kleinen Kreis
um Bortoluzzi und Blocher.
Die SVP Schweiz soll
auf die Zürcher Linie einschwenken.
Der Unmut über
die nationale Parteileitung wächst.
Die SVP plätschere politisch
nur noch so dahin.
Die Berner Mentalität
hat Einzug gehalten.
Ein bisschen behäbig, stabil -
behäbig, aber ohne Power.
Das ist wohl der Unterschied.
Und das geht einfach nicht
bei der SVP,
weil man immer mit Power
gearbeitet und dadurch gewonnen hat.
Und diese Behäbigkeit
führt dann allenfalls zu Verlusten.
Wichtig seien klare Feindbilder -
z.B. die EU.
Für mich fehlen hier
die Sterne der EU.
Die gehören eigentlich dorthin.
Aber das kommt ja vielleicht noch.
Man weiss noch nicht recht,
wer der Krake ist, oder?
Ja, ja, dieser Krake muss natürlich
noch bezeichnet werden.
Das ist klar.
Ich erhoffe mir natürlich schwer,
dass die EU uns noch mehr plagt.
Dann wird das die Leute ärgern
und v.a. unsere Leute mobilisieren,
damit sie wählen gehen.
Diese Hoffnung habe ich natürlich.
Daran orientiere ich mich ein wenig.
Die Kampagne
ist auch so ausgerichtet,
dass man versucht,
das an die Leute zu bringen.
Als Reaktion auf die Klimadebatte
hat die Zürcher SVP
den sog. Klimateufel erfunden ―
und lange an einem Slogan gefeilt.
Das ist eher ... Das ist auch etwas,
das im Text gestrichen wurde.
Weil man fand,
das sei nicht unbedingt das Thema.
Stark ist, wenn man agiert.
Wenn man reagiert,
ist das nicht unbedingt Stärke,
sondern eine Art Hinterherlaufen,
in der Hoffnung,
man könnte doch noch
etwas daraus gewinnen.
Das ist natürlich eindeutig ...
2015 machte sich der SVP-Wahlkampf
praktisch von alleine.
2015, also bei den letzten
eidgenössischen Wahlen,
hatte man von daher
natürlich etwas Glück.
Weil es dort
gerade einen Aufruhr gab -
wegen der Einwanderung,
wegen der Flüchtlinge.
Das war ein wenig ein Glücksfall.
Für die SVP, oder?
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Für unser Ergebnis,
das wir damals erzielt haben.
Ein anderer SVP-Klassiker
sind die kriminellen Ausländer.
Unvergessen sind das sog.
Schäfchen-Plakat und ähnliche Sujets.
Die kriminellen Ausländer
sind kein Thema mehr?
Gut, die Masseneinwanderung,
kriminelle Ausländer ...
Da kann man natürlich auch
aus gewissen Statistiken erheben,
wann so etwas passiert,
und etwas daraus machen.
Aber es müsste ja
wieder ein Anlass sein,
damit das wieder etwas mehr ...
... thematisiert würde -
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
(Originalkommentar) Der Beitritt
zum Europäischen Wirtschaftsraum
scheitert am Volks-
und am Ständemehr.
Es ist kein Rezept,
die Grenzen zu öffnen.
Nach dem EWR-Nein war die Hierarchie
in der SVP klar:
Blocher und sein Zürcher Flügel
gaben den Ton an.
... mehr Demokratie,
mehr Regulierung ...
Bortoluzzi gehörte über 20 Jahre lang
zum engsten Führungszirkel um Blocher
und war entsprechend einflussreich.
Er sei eine zentrale Figur gewesen,
sagen SVP-Insider.
Wenn es irgendwelche wichtigen Dinge
zu entscheiden gegeben habe,
habe Christoph Blocher immer gesagt,
Toni Bortoluzzi wolle er dabei haben,
der habe einen guten Bauch.
War das so?
Das weiss ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich
dachte er, einen grossen Bauch.
Nein, einfach das Gespür ...
- Einen politischen Bauch?
Ja, das Gespür für die Leute.
Das Gespür für die Leute am Boden.
Er ist gelernter Schreiner
und wurde deshalb von Aussenstehenden
oft unterschätzt.
Intern war das nie so.
Er galt als Dossier-fest,
wurde respektiert und gefürchtet.
Ich halte sehr viel ...
- Sie können ja mal als Gast kommen.
... von deiner Politik.
Hinterzimmertreffen
in einem Zürcher Landgasthof
mit ehemaligen und aktuellen SVP-
Grössen. Hier werden Fäden gezogen.
Du hast den Fehler gemacht.
Ich habe gesagt, er solle
nach hinten, Frau Fehr nach vorne.
Die politische Karriere von Hans
Fehrs Tochter soll gepusht werden.
Wir müssen viel mehr
Deutsch sprechen.
Das ist so.
Denn unsere Wähler
sind auf der einfachen Ebene.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ein wiederkehrendes Themen der Runde:
der schleichende Bedeutungsverlust,
den die Zürcher SVP
in der nationalen Partei
seit Blochers Abwahl
aus dem Bundesrat erleben musste.
Das soll sich ändern.
Das ist mein persönliches Anliegen.
Ich hoffe,
dass wir mit den nächsten Wahlen
da wieder etwas Schub geben können.
Dass es Leute gibt, die in der
schweizerischen Partei einsteigen
und die Führung mindestens
ein Stück weit übernehmen.
Was heisst das?
Dass man z.B. einen Zürcher SVP-
Präsidenten national haben sollte?
Genau.
Das ist etwas Wichtiges für mich.
Dass man nachher
wieder mit Leuten ...
Ob das jetzt der Parteipräsident ist
oder einer, der in der Parteileitung
ein bisschen eine Bedeutung hat,
das spielt eigentlich keine Rolle.
Aber dass es Zürcher sind,
die auf schweizerischer Ebene wieder
mehr Gewicht bekommen als heute.
Die erste Sitzung der kantonalen
Parteileitung nach der Sommerpause.
Also, was wir sehen, kurz und
einfach für euch zusammengefasst:
Andelfingen ist gut,
die haben mehrere Veranstaltungen.
Nichts Grosses, aber mehrere.
Ähm ...
Dann ...
Meilen ist gut, die machen
noch etwas Grösseres am ...
Es geht nur noch um Administratives.
Die strategischen Entscheidungen
sind gefallen.
Die Plakatsujets
wurden inzwischen finalisiert.
Die EU-Sterne des Krakens
fehlen aber weiterhin.
Man müsste natürlich bereit sein,
wenn sich irgendein Thema ergibt,
das politisch aktuell ist.
Bei dem vielleicht
noch einige Korrekturen nötig sind.
Aber so sieht es momentan nicht aus.
Dann lanciert die SVP Schweiz
das sog. Wurmplakat -
und löst weitherum Entsetzen aus.
Nicht nur bei politischen Gegnern,
sondern auch in den eigenen Reihen.
Hä? Ja, ja.
Du bist ein starker Mann,
das muss ich sagen, gleich zwei.
Aber es ist natürlich noch Morgen,
da hast du noch Kraft.
Bortoluzzi und ein SVP-Kollege,
ein vormaliger Malermeister,
wollen rund um Affoltern
Plakate aufstellen.
So ein Apfelplakat habt ihr nicht?
- Nein, eben nicht.
Wieso nicht?
- Ich weiss es auch nicht.
Das sind die Plakate der Schweiz und
das ist jenes vom Kanton Zürich.
Wir sind für den Kanton Zürich
zuständig.
Aber der Kollege hier hätte
gerne so ein Apfelplakat gehabt.
Denn er ist etwas eklig.
Und wie ist das Apfelplakat
bei Ihnen angekommen?
Wie?
Wie kam das Apfelplakat
bei Ihnen an?
Bei mir?
- Ja.
Bei mir kam das sehr gut an.
Weil ich aus Erfahrung
natürlich weiss,
dass man ein wenig provozieren muss,
wenn man ein Thema
auf die Agenda bringen will.
Komm, Simon, einsteigen.
Wir sind am Arbeiten.
Jetzt habe ich noch vergessen,
mich anzugurten.
Aber du musst nicht unbedingt.
Wir kennen die Polizisten.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Die Plakatständer
lagern in einem Schuppen am Waldrand.
Zeit für eine Einführung
in die kühl kalkulierte
Provokationslogik der SVP:
Zuerst eine Bombe platzen lassen,
dann ein Thema
auf die politische Agenda drücken.
Wenn du
eine intensive Provokation machst
und die Leute dadurch erschreckst,
dann musst du gleichzeitig sagen,
worum es geht.
Es hat ja Inhalt.
Es ist nicht nur der Ausdruck, den
man im Moment plakativ wahrnimmt,
es hat Inhalt und Hintergrund.
Und das muss man erklären.
Und dann wird die Provokation
sofort relativiert.
Primäres Ziel dieses Wahlkampfes
sei nicht, neue Wähler zu gewinnen,
sondern die eigenen zu mobilisieren.
Das Mobilisieren erfolgt natürlich
u.a. durch die Provokation.
Die Eigenen merken,
dass es um etwas geht.
Und sie spüren,
dass wir mit unserer politischen
Haltung unter Druck stehen.
Und ich glaube,
das führt schon dazu ...
... dass die Leute
dann eher wählen gehen.
Die Mobilisierung sei bei diesen
Wahlen entscheidend für die SVP.
Denn die Analyse
der Zürcher Kantonalwahlen zeigte:
Genau das war nicht gelungen und
hatte zu herben Verlusten geführt.
Nein, das macht nichts.
Das stört niemanden hier.
Oder?
Schon wieder etwas gemacht.
So, Simon, einsteigen.
Bortoluzzi
ist Plakatchef der Zürcher SVP.
D.h., er muss kontrollieren,
ob flächendeckend plakatiert wurde.
Mit Plakaten
gewinne man keine Wahlen, sagt er,
aber man könne sie verlieren,
wenn zu wenig Plakate stünden.
Ende Gelände.
- Ja, ja.
Nein,
hier müssen wir also nicht durch.
Umkehren.
Jetzt sind wir natürlich hier
fast an der Grenze.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
* Sanfte Klarinettenklänge *
Dann kämen wir hier wieder ...
Ja, also.
Ich glaube, ich habe es im Griff.
Ich habe es im Griff.
Er nimmt sich mehrere Tage Zeit
und fährt kreuz und quer
durch den Kanton Zürich,
um sich einen Überblick über
die Plakatsituation zu verschaffen.
Jetzt müssen wir hier schauen,
was wir da haben.
Hier habe ich z.B.
einfach nichts gesehen.
Dann werde ich also ...
... diese Leuten hier anrufen
und sagen:
"Was ist los mit euch?" oder
ich teile es dem Sekretariat mit.
Ja, siehst du,
da ist auch noch einer.
Gut, und hier auch.
Das sind Bauern,
da sind auch zwei SVPler drauf.
Man muss zum Ausdruck bringen,
dass man etwas will.
Es mobilisiert auch
die eigenen Leute.
Zeit für eine grundsätzliche
Lagebeurteilung
im Restaurant Sonne in Dielsdorf.
Wir hoffen einfach,
dass die Sonne geöffnet hat.
Hm?
- Ja.
Wahlplakate
müssen möglichst einfach sein,
aber die Welt ist kompliziert,
nicht wahr?
Im Grossen und Ganzen
ist es nicht so kompliziert,
wie es z.T. dargestellt wird.
Ich dachte, es sei eher umgekehrt?
- Nein.
Es wird einfach dargestellt
und ist eigentlich kompliziert.
Ja, natürlich sind die Details
vielleicht komplex.
Aber das Wesentliche, das, worüber
der Stimmbürger befinden muss,
eine Richtung,
in die es gehen sollte,
das habe ich nie
als so kompliziert empfunden.
Der Wahlkampf
ist auf der Zielgeraden.
Die SVP Zürich
trifft sich auf dem Münsterhof
zu einem sog. Mobilisierungsanlass.
Die Prognosen
sagen der Partei Verluste voraus.
Inoffizielles Ziel ist es,
diese möglichst kleinzuhalten.
Die offizielle Devise lautet:
Optimismus verbreiten -
allenthalben und in allen Farben.
Morgen, Thomas!
- Hoi, sali.
Da hast du einen schönen,
weissen Anzug.
Willst du auch einen?
Warte, den Kragen
muss man etwas zurechtrücken,
damit du eine gute Gattung machst.
Ich war letzte Woche bei dir.
- Ja, ich bin ...
Du warst in Elm.
- Ja, am Fenster montieren.
Ich hatte Aufgaben.
- Gut.
Auch Konrad Langhart, der gewesene
Kantonalpräsident, ist gekommen.
Man würdigt sich keines Blickes.
Langhart steht zwar weiter
auf der Nationalratsliste der SVP,
aber seine politische Karriere
dürfte vorbei sein.
Und seine
beginnt vielleicht erst richtig.
Alle jungen Frauen!
- Roger, schon frühmorgens.
Sali, Roger.
Alle jungen Frauen umarmen dich.
Hoi.
- Sali.
Sali, Roger.
Geht es gut
mit dem neuen Kantonsrat?
Regierungsrat meinst du.
- Ah ja, dem Regierungsrat.
Suchst du noch ein Plätzchen?
Komm, setz dich doch hierhin.
* Schweizer Nationalhymne *
Es ist ein Folklore-Anlass
für Gleichgesinnte,
aber auch eine Möglichkeit,
im kleinen Kreis
für nach den Wahlen vorzuspuren.
Das Ziel ist klar: Die Zürcher wollen
wieder das Sagen haben in der SVP.
Wir müssen die Nationalräte
zusammennehmen
und ihnen sagen, wo es langgeht.
Ja, weisst du,
dann müssen wir schauen ...
Wir werden ja zehn oder elf haben.
In jeder Kommission
muss einer von uns sitzen.
Und das muss nachher
im Kanton Zürich
eine gewisse Ausstrahlung haben.
Denn in gewissen Dossiers
haben wir heute niemanden.
Die Show ist vorbei.
Und die Strategie
ist schon vor dem Wahltag definiert:
In allen wichtigen Kommissionen
sollen künftig wieder
Zürcher SVPler sitzen,
in allen wichtigen Dossiers
sollen sie den Ton angeben.
So dominiert man eine Partei.
So geht Politik.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Laura Thomann - 2019